hey guys making a quick video I'm about
to leave but I got to sneak this in it's
been a pretty hardcore day and some I'm
not my normal off-the-wall bouncing kind
of self so a little bit more thoughtful
because there's a ton of [ __ ] running
through my head after 11 hours of this
day
[Music]
I do want to talk about the Amazon
acquisition of Whole Foods I love it for
many different reasons
July 5th 1994 she like 5th 1994 is the
day that Amazon launched Whole Foods was
valued at 220 million though you guys
think I'm an amateur huh
Whole Foods was valued at 220 million
dollars at the time I'm always
fascinated by being historically correct
which I talked about with myself and
trying thinks being strictly correct
allows the person that started way
behind to win right to me it's
fascinating that it's Amazon buying
Whole Foods instead of Whole Foods
buying Amazon or the fact that had Whole
Foods been run by people that bet on the
internet and started with food instead
of books like would it be the other way
around would would would would Whole
Foods be eating up the world instead of
Amazon eating up the world there's a
clip here that I'm gonna that I'm gonna
show you right now that was from what
just like two or three weeks ago where I
was talking about - yeah where I was
talking about Amazon if it's entered
into the stereo world what would it mean
what if they bought I think people don't
understand how big these companies are I
wonder how many people like whoa Amazon
bought Whole Foods easily and and when
Facebook buys X and Apple buys why I
don't think people understand what's
happening here the new world is gonna
eat the old world it's gonna eat it it's
gonna eat it my friends that's what's
gonna continue to happen I think today
is a landmark day because a new age
company Amazon is not old a new age
company you know I was night there was
an 18 I was 18 years old when Amazon
launched this is not a new company
excuse me not an old company it's a new
company Whole Foods itself is kind of a
new company but what this means to the
other people in the grocery business
like this is this is a shot in the air
like I want people to pay attention this
clip is me talking about Amazon entering
that world and this and what I really
want to talk about in this video is one
if you're winning start eating up your
own self don't let somebody else do it
if you're winning right now in your
business put yourself out of business
don't let somebody else
do it right don't let somebody else buy
you buy them that's number one number
two please pay attention to what
Facebook and Apple and Google have the
capabilities of doing and start figuring
out what that means to you and and how
you're innovating and and and thing
whether you're running a hundred dollar
business or a hundred million dollar
business that you take away from this
innovation always wins if you're right
you always win if you're right you
always win right play the apps three
real [ __ ] a-list celebrities and me
how do I get there by being right by
being right by building my brand the
right way that gave me the leverage to
be on that panel and so I just want to
inspire somebody from this video to do
the right thing on podcast and do the
right Alexa flash two to triple down on
their ability on Facebook to understand
influencer marketing to to see there's a
white space and snapchat while everybody
thinks Instagram is pulling you know
putting them out of business like be
smart be smart because if you're smart
and you execute you start buying things
that started off way ahead of you
[Music]